[Music]
hey everybody here we are back again
on a wednesday probably it's a wednesday
i guess yeah it's wednesday
hopefully the lawn crew was done yeah
they're out there running around because
holy [ __ ] that was so loud
like okay i had ours and then theirs
see i thought it was two different days
i thought ours was friday and theirs was
wednesday well we got a new crew
oh okay so it's a different day so yeah
the old ones got replaced oh all right i
see what you're doing yeah okay
they're better than the old ones yeah
well yeah we got the we got the
they're all noisy we got that crew
through our landlord
yeah they got connections and all that
our landlord owns 50 houses that's that
same [ __ ] lawn crew
anyway yeah go ahead and go ahead and
get to it jenny
all right so this is a movie from 2017
that we are discussing today i had kind
of like heard about it through the
grapevine but i didn't really see it
come up on anything
i think that the only streaming service
it's on is hulu which seems a little
strange
i was watching another review of it and
the two guys on there were like yeah we
heard about this movie we don't really
see it because
it's on hulu and he's like i never
really think of hulu when i think of
like wanting to watch newer movies
because i think of it more as like a tv
series type of
streaming service which i guess it kind
of is but they do have a lot of movies
so this is called tragedy girls now this
is a horror comedy
it was directed by tyler mcintyre who
was the same guy
that did patchwork which did we review
that
because we watched it i remember
watching it because i think it was on
shutter and i really really liked that
hard time remembering that one yeah it
was it was really really good
it was kind of like a frankenstein story
but like it was a girl and she was like
sewing
oh yeah yeah yeah i remember i liked
that movie a lot um
so this one is kind of like
this movie is kind of like there's these
two girls
um they're in high school and uh
one of them is named michaela and one of
them is named sadie
i love that their last names michaela's
last name is hooper like toby hooper
and sadie's last name is cunningham like
sean cunningham there's all kind of like
little horror easter eggs in this like
you can tell that the dude that made it
is like super into horror movies like
they make reference to like dario
argento they make reference to
martyrs um there's a murder in it that
looks very much like the very famous
like pole
murder from uh cannibal holocaust
there's all that kind of [ __ ] going on
in there so that's kind of like a fun
little thing so these two girls um are
basically
aspiring serial killers like they have a
blog
called the tragedy girls and they're
trying to get
attention for their blog so what they
their first plan that they decide to do
is there's this killer running around
it's this town called rosedale and
there's this killer running around
called the rosedale ripper but they feel
like
some of the murders kind of look like
accidents or the cops aren't doing
enough to solve them or whatever
so they plan they're gonna kidnap this
guy
and get like some pointers uh so they do
that and then
like he doesn't really want to cooperate
and all those other shits they come up
with all these other kind of like
schemes
the funny thing about this movie is that
there's like a lot of
the gore gags in it are really really
good like i really really like um
the one like this one annoying chick
that they kill and they cut her all up
into pieces and like she gets sawed in
half and all i said it's really really
funny
and uh one guy gets killed in like a gym
and like the they drop the [ __ ] bar
on him and like
takes the top of his head off or
something like that it's like really so
there's really good gore in it
but the most hilarious thing is that
this
is essentially it reminded me a lot of
like real dark high school comedies like
heathers or jawbreaker or mean girls or
something like that
except with an over-the-top like slasher
movie element to it
yeah because these two girls are just
like
sociopaths they don't care about anybody
they don't care about
i mean all they care about is getting
famous and
you know what i mean and they're just
like not grossed out by killing but
they'll just kill anybody that gets in
their way they do not give a single [ __ ]
and they're just like super super
shallow about it
but in the same but by the same token
their characters are also kind of
charming and kind of likable too
so it's just comedy yeah yeah yeah and
it's it's a very very very
dark comedy yeah like some of the [ __ ]
that happens in it
i didn't really i didn't really like it
it just it really wasn't my thing i mean
maybe some people might like it
i think a lot of it has to do with the
mindset that you're in you know when
you're watching the movie yeah
but for me it just wasn't really to my
taste and i like horror comedies
yeah it's just um i don't know just it
just really couldn't hold my attention
to me it just seemed kind of like more
the same
it seemed real samey to me well it was
it was
similar in tone like to some more recent
stuff that we've
reviewed like um like uh we sum in the
darkness
um or satanic panic or something
it's kind of like has a tone like that i
think the sense of humor in this one was
much darker
and also i kind of liked the
juxtaposition between this really dark
sense of humor
and also this almost kind of like
like touching and heartfelt story about
friendship about like the two
like the two if there's friendship and
like how you know
friends before anything else but it's
like the way that it's
plays out in the movie is like super
[ __ ] up there's something about it it
just didn't pull me into it i really
wasn't interested in it i didn't buy it
that's that's what i did you know what i
mean it just seemed kind of like
the you know i didn't really buy the
premise of it
i wasn't really pulled into the
characters uh
and you know there's really nothing
wrong with the movie in terms of you
know what i mean like
the quality was high the acting was
pretty good
um the edit was pretty good but there
was just there's just something about
the movie it just i just didn't
i didn't feel it i will say i mean i
liked this movie i probably liked
patchwork
better this guy's other movie um which i
think came out a year or two after
that's one about the pretty girl that
was sewed all the girls together right
yeah well all the all these girls got
sewn together and they were trying to
like
they had to like work together to like a
killer sewed them all together
that's right and then they had to kind
of like the same one i was thinking no
that you the one you're thinking of is
may that came that came out a long time
it was may was the best one out of the
ones we just mentioned right now
yeah i want to uh review that one of
these days i think it's pretty good i
think it's come up in the polls a couple
of times but it hasn't been picked
that's
crazy that's a creepy one yeah it was
like a little weird girl that like is
trying to like make
she's trying to make the perfect i could
buy that story
you know this one it's almost kind of
like
well like i said it it has a very like
high school black comedy kind of feel to
it
in the sense that these are very shallow
characters and all they care about is
their status
yeah as serial killers and so everything
is geared toward
you know trying to get followers on
twitter trying to do this that the other
thing and it's like they will
just like kill anybody that gets in
their way and it's like the funny part
too is that they kill a couple of people
and then
it it doesn't really get um attributed
to them like
it's either like oh the dude just ran
away or it was an accident or something
like that and they get pissed off
so then they have to like kill the
person you know the next person but they
have to make sure that it's a murder so
they'd like have to do it like the most
crazy
over-the-top [ __ ] way that you could
possibly imagine
but yeah it's gonna it's gonna depend on
how you feel about movies that are about
teenage girls that are about social
media
um and that kind of i don't know like
like i said i like black comedies so i
thought this was like pretty funny i
don't think it was as funny as
we summoned the darkness or you know
heather's even i don't think it was as
funny as that
but some of the scenes in it like some
of the gore scenes and [ __ ] like that
and some of the little homages that they
gave to like other
movies were really really clever i
thought and were really well done
i also liked too that the two girls
were they were kind of like from
opposite sides of the tracks because one
was like from lived in a trailer park
and like the other one was kind of like
upper middle class
but they both had really nice families
you know what i mean it wasn't like you
know they came from like trashy families
and oh that's why they were serial
killer they just were evil
you know what i mean like that all their
parents were nice and loving and
supportive and everything like that but
they were just still terrible horrible
people
and yet you still kind of i don't know
if you're rooting for them necessarily
because you're like yeah kill everybody
but some of the
some of the people they killed you were
like yeah kill that person but
you know some of the people like didn't
deserve it but that's kind of
for me it just didn't gel it didn't yeah
the thing it didn't come together into
something that
pulled me into the story i i don't know
just
i just i just thought it was just kind
of blah yeah yeah so i don't i don't
know if
i mean it seems like it's gotten really
good reviews it's a fun i i you know i
thought it was a really fun movie and
it's like you know
like i said it's not quite as funny as a
couple of other ones that i've seen
recently but it's still like pretty
funny and like a lot of the courses
i guess your mileage may vary you know
well that's just like
i mean every movie i don't think there's
any movie
in existence that is universally loved
by everybody you're always going to get
one
grumpy [ __ ] that is like you
know what
think of what is what is the most
beloved movie that you can think of i
don't even know if i can think of one
star wars
yeah well that one's too that was too
obvious well the first one yeah the
first one
now or okay how about jaws can you think
there has to be somebody out there
as awesome as jaws is there has to be
one wrong person out there
that hates jaws although i don't know if
i would want to meet that person
you know i don't hate jaws but i was
never really i didn't really think jaws
was a big thing
in the days than the time the jaws came
out i mean i could enjoy it now
but in those days i just only think i
remembered about it as a kid was just
the dude
dude that's the soundtrack and that
chick sent that and that chick in the
very beginning [ __ ] swimming naked i
[ __ ] loved that part
well of course she did i was about seven
i liked this movie yeah i like that part
no sure don't eat her
yeah yeah that was the shark was just
about everybody
yeah that one didn't really stick out to
me
maybe you should watch it again i was
seeing it recently
i'm just i'm just talking about i'm
trying to think of like a movie
that is so beloved that
if you said that you didn't like it
everybody would just accuse you of just
trying to be a contrarian
what i would say is the one that made
one the one from that era that made
a lot more impact on me was close
encounters of the third kind i [ __ ]
loved that movie
yeah and i i really like close
encounters too but it's not
one of my favorites from that era okay i
really like that movie but it's not one
of my favorites of there
you have to think too that i'm more a
horror person than a sci-fi person
you know what i mean um so any movie
that's more horror
oriented is going to be like more my
thing than a sci-fi thing yeah
other than like alien and stuff like
that but ali well like i said alien i
don't really even consider that sci-fi
so it's basically just a monster movie
is telling me to re-watch jaws i saw it
i saw jaws a couple years ago we watched
it together remember
yeah it was maybe two years ago yeah i
like it it's good yeah
yeah i'm not saying i'm not saying it's
sophie says raiders of the lost ark
yeah that's a good that's a good call
yeah that very first i don't i don't
think i've
ever heard of a single person that
doesn't like raiders of the lost ark and
maybe and maybe the first back to the
future
yeah like i said if i'm sure they're out
like all the backs of the future i'm
sure they're out there
but yeah you know and i i just feel like
those movies are so awesome and so
beloved that anybody that said they
didn't they that they genuinely didn't
like that movie i would just accuse them
of truth i want to know
i want to know if tila got around to
watching the hand she said she was gonna
watch it yeah she's just gonna watch it
if you like conan then you gotta see the
[ __ ] the opposite of conan which is
[ __ ] the hand
which is really weird because you don't
think those two movies have anything to
do with one another but they actually
kind of yeah oliver stone was involved
in both
and conan conan is in the second one did
we mention that oliver stone also played
a bum
in the hand you had a cameo as a bomb
yep he played a really good drunken bomb
yep he was only in one scene but you
know what i mean i was just kind of like
hey there's oliver stone right there and
he was like
sounded like me at the end of the last
at the last saturday show
all right so uh what promised to watch
the hand
after work today okay i promise okay you
got to see the hand
and uh was there another one that i was
talking about
i don't know you might want to see heavy
metal sondra says i know somebody who
doesn't like back to the future i don't
trust that guy yeah
yeah i don't think i'd want to hang out
with anybody like back to the future
we gotta do we gotta we're we're doing a
retrospective on heavy metal aren't we
you know what it keeps coming up in the
poll but something else always like gets
out like gets outvoted it always gets
outvoted
i we watched it the other night and fire
and ice is on tubie
as well like because that's kind of the
companion piece yeah
for um heavy metal i think i saw bits of
it when i was a kid but i don't think i
ever saw the whole thing and now and you
realize well i haven't seen the whole
maybe i saw an edited version because
that [ __ ]
that thing had a lot of [ __ ] nudity
in it a lot of animated sex and stuff
but heavy metal is [ __ ] great i used
to love that [ __ ] uh magazine when it
came
uh there's an illustrated like sci-fi
adventure magazine yeah
you can still get it like you can get
downloads of it online or you know
see digital copies of it online but that
heavy metal i was impressed on on uh i
was impressed on that one
it was a lot like the magazine yeah tila
said is it animated yeah
yeah it's animated with a really good
like [ __ ] rock and and new wave
soundtrack from what was that 1980 or 81
1980 i think that came out yeah 80 or 81
okay
it's about this damn green ball which is
a it's an alien being
that transcends all time and dimensions
and it's the personification of
everything that is evil
what is that thing called the loch nars
yeah and this
the loch nar goes through all these
stories and each story some terrible
[ __ ] happens about the loch nar and um
and it's across time and across
different dimensions and
it happens in different worlds and a lot
of the stuff
a lot of the stories at least one of
them takes place
in a series that showed up in heavy
metal it was uh the one about the uh
the the the the boy that went into
another dimension and he's a bad he was
a wimp over here but over there
he was a [ __ ] a badass [ __ ] all
muscular with no [ __ ] hair
and he was [ __ ] nailing all these
real hot barbarian chicks he's in this
barbarian dimension
and he's over there [ __ ] with the
loch narc kind of reminds me of that
one of our friend one of our one of our
fans send me sent me the illustrated
magazine of it yeah yeah yeah i haven't
read it though but it was called um
yeah what the hell was that kid's name
oh [ __ ] tran
tr uh [ __ ] where is that isn't that in
here
i don't know it might be back there like
on the pile with the other
yeah i don't remember yeah there's all
the weird tails
yeah i think i took that into the back
room to read it and never got around to
it yeah you might have something
to remember so it might be like on the
shelf somewhere yeah
um yeah we need them
we need to re-watch like fire and ice
and stuff too because like i said that's
for free on tubing
like i said they're both in the um in my
queue like every now and then heavy
metal comes up on the
patreon polls but it always gets out
voted by something else you want to see
heavy metal
you want to see the hand and you want to
see fire and ice fire and ice is like
animated uh
conan it's kind of like that and also
it's on that's free on
uh to be fire nice fire nice yeah um
i would also like to recommend this one
is a little bit harder to find but if
you like
animation that's kind of like an adult
story
um i would also recommend rock and roll
which is
canadian um and it's one of my favorite
animated films one of the one of the
weird one of the cool things about that
about that heavy metal blu-ray that i
have is that there's a deleted scene in
there
that was gonna be in the movie and it's
just hand illustrated and it looks
[ __ ] badass it's
looks like something out of pink floyd
the wall and it's about the loch nar
that damn green ball
and it shows it in earth's past
with [ __ ] cellular organisms eating
each other because of the lachnar and
then
multicellular organisms and then
dinosaurs eating each other and the loch
nars there [ __ ]
absorbing the the evil energy and then
cavemen killing the [ __ ] mammoths and
the
then it goes up into roman er barbarians
and romans [ __ ] killing each other
the the french revolution people cutting
their heads off
and the loch nars there jack the ripper
murdering women in the loch nars there
it's just this
swirling hand animation of it happening
with this really spooky [ __ ]
classical music of this thing going
through earth's
history [ __ ] [ __ ] up and it even goes
didn't it go through
how did it end didn't it go to through
space and in the future
i can't run it i think or did it just
stop in the present day
or i think it stopped in kind of like a
blade runner type
universe have to look at it again it was
really eerie
and that was what i remembered about
that heavy metal magazine is just
how eerie it was it was just kind of
it a lot of those stories were just kind
of creepy
yeah they were sci-fi adventure kind of
blade runner-ish in a way
well they jumped all over like like like
this movie we're talking about well
heavy metal i mean the first
story was very blade runner-esque i i
thought
yeah i think that i think that comic
book was called dan
dan wren or something like i can't
remember
yeah sandra is saying um about ratched i
have been actually wanting to watch that
i was gonna watch it uh one night
because it's on netflix
in case you guys didn't know and then i
saw like a couple people on
facebook like a couple friends of mine
like talking about it and they were like
man we were so excited for this and it's
so so bad
and i was like oh man maybe maybe i'll
watch it later like because i was kind
of bummed out
so i just like never got around to
because now i got
i got hulu and then i kind of got
involved in
castle rock so i have to finish that off
first and then maybe i'll do ratched
because i do actually want to watch
that because you know i don't know i
think it was called damn
d-e-m yeah it was like a short name you
know i can't remember
i can't remember yeah it was about this
wimpy kid who could go and he went into
another dimension where he was a badass
and a hero and [ __ ] he was totally
opposite of what he what he was like i
said that he's like a babe
that kind of reminds me of the gore
novels which they made i've only seen
the movie that they did on mystery
science theater which i think is called
outlaw of gore
um about like the kind of dorky teacher
guy that gets sucked into another
dimension
and over there he's like a barbarian
like a big hero and [ __ ] like that and
he has like a hot queen
wife or whatever yeah and it's like a
ring like that sucks him into another
dimension
yeah i'm pretty sure it was called damn
yeah something like that all right i'll
go back and look at it again we got
after i've seen it now that i've seen
the movie i want to go back and
read the illustrated novel yeah yeah
well you need to find it i think that
was only part
it's either with my weird tails back
there or you took it
i think i took it back there to read it
and never got around to it oh okay i
gotta go look and look for it again
all right all right so uh i guess
that'll do it for
today's show right yeah it's uh
wednesday so
i guess we'll be back for another live
stream on saturday
doing kind of a cool creepy historical
uh topic coming up on saturday
uh but until then you know tomorrow
witching hour
friday we've got a movie retrospective
coming up so you guys can
watch that kind of stuff and uh we'll
talk to you guys again live
on saturday and uh thanks for dropping
by so bye